so du weißt du ob sie zum mainz ist oder
das vom lieferdienst das ist das
schmeckt so flach einfach hoch denn zwar
gewürze drin aber diesen so lang
wahnsinnig romantisch schärfe drin hat
die gewisse schärfe gewürze sind sind
geil das max frisch am point ich muss
sagen dass sie recht eindeutig
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute haben wir mal
gedacht koche ich das was ich mir sonst
immer beim lieferdienst bestelle also
ich koche sehr gerne aber manchmal gibt
es auch so tage da habe ich auch keine
lust und haben sich bestellen und dann
einfach was haben sie nimmt dann immer
eine pizza und ich immer ein curry ich
berufs mir grad mal auf ein gelbes curry
mit tofu da ist so ein bisschen gemüse
mit drin da ist auch reis mit dabei und
alle zutaten für dieses rezept habe ich
gerade zu hause und ich würde sagen ich
koche das jetzt bestellen aber parallel
werde jetzt nicht gucken wer schneller
ist wenn ich garantiere euch diesen
bestimmt schon als ich aber ich werde
den hansa später blind verkosten dass
man ihnen nicht sagen was ich gekocht
haben soll starten jetzt direkt mit dem
tofu ich muss sagen wenn man kein fan
ist dann muss man einfach noch mal
vielleicht ausprobieren erstens die
richtige marke zu verwenden und das
richtig zuzubereiten wenn ihr jetzt
dürfen verwendet der komplett eingelegt
ist dann kann es helfen wenn ihr den
auch in so einem küchentuch wickelt aber
irgendwie so eine schwere panne oder so
um drauflegt und dann einfach 20 minuten
warte man merke dass die flüssigkeit
austritt das ist ganz wichtig damit der
tofu einfach später von außen richtig
schön knusprig wird und von innen schön
soft und muss ein tofu schmeckt erst mal
und riecht auch nach gar nichts aber die
gewürze machen es später aus wenn ich
das sie erledigt habe werde ich den tofu
in gleichmäßig große stücke schneiden
dann wird er in der heißen pfanne mit
etwas kokosöl angebraten
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt schon mal mein tofu
angebraten das braucht auch so ungefähr
89 minuten ihr könnt das vorab schon mal
salzen und pfeffern seht ihr das hab ich
vergessen das hole ich jetzt ganz
schnell nach später werde ich auf jeden
fall auch nochmal mit salz abschmecken
da kann man auch andere gewürze mit dazu
und was sich auch parallel gemacht hat
ist schon mal den reis gekocht einfach
den raise ich habe hier basmati
langkornreis genommen einfach schön
abwaschen und lauwarm oder kaltem wasser
das ist in dem fall egal bis unten das
wasser fast klar wieder rauskommt so
spürt ihr die stärke raus und der reise
ist nicht so klebrig es sind mögen ist
klebrig dann lass es ruhig aber ich mag
es lieber so ist habe ich jetzt nebenbei
hier schon mal vorbereitet muss gerade
vor sich hin ich gebe jetzt hier nochmal
mein komplettes vorbereitetes gemüse mit
dazu das habe ich schon in mundgerechte
stücke geschnitten ich mag es
tatsächlich immer ein bisschen größer
und so kommt auch geliefert wenn die
stücke auch mal ein bisschen größer es
gebe jetzt hier chili mit rein nicht zu
viel ich mag sie mich nicht so scharf
deswegen nehme ich da auch immer gelbes
curry gelbes currys man nicht ganz so
scharf wie rotes da kommen jetzt noch
knoblauchzehen mit dazu einfach rein
fressen und dann kann das nämlich auch
noch mal schön
anbraten so ein bisschen im rest feld
und daneben alle anderen zutaten mit
dazu zumindest was das gemüse angeht
[Musik]
das gemüse kommt jetzt noch mal richtig
schön langsam dünsten auch nochmal so
fünf minuten ihr seht dann auch das ist
so ein bisschen ein feld und ein
bisschen weicher wird es darf aber ruhig
noch ein bisschen bis haben und jetzt
kommt so ein bisschen würze mit dazu
gleich kommen natürlich noch mal salz
rein ich gebe jetzt hier nochmals curry
dazu curry ist ein kind der regel immer
eine mischung aus vielen zutaten da
könnte einfach eure liebste
gewürzmischung nehmen ich nehme meine
und die haie achtung wer versteht den
insider und carrie
[Applaus]
& carry doug und carrie
hhv
wir haben sogar das etikett eben doug
heffernan
ps uniform gemacht in diesem grünen also
alle king of queens in fahrer müssen
jetzt auch vielfahrer kommentieren ob
die das erkannt haben dann gebe ich
mango chutney dazu irgendetwas süßes
brauche es und ich habe auch gesehen in
der zutatenliste von einem lieferdienst
steht auch mango chutney drin wobei ich
sagen muss ich habe mich jetzt nicht ein
zu einfacher gehalten weil ich nie mit
auch das gemüse was ich da hatte falls
er keinen mango chutney da habt dann
könnt ihr auch zum beispiel honig nehmen
oder agaven dicksaft
so auch noch mit dazu und
anschließend kommt kokosmilch mit rein
und dies am anfang nicht wo man so ein
bisschen klumpig das legt sich aber
gleich wieder weil sich die stoffe
voneinander getrennt haben
das sieht jetzt erstmal so im ersten
moment nicht so appetitlich aus aber ich
schwöre es euch innerhalb von wenigen
sekunden verflüssigt sich alles wieder
also wenn ihr manchmal auch so
kokosmilch in dosen harz schüttelt das
ruhig ordentlich falls ihr nicht alles
verwendet weil dann verbindet sich alles
wieder miteinander dann könnte zum
beispiel die hälfte verwenden und die
angriffe wieder stehen lassen und dann
habt ihr damit keine probleme
[Musik]
so inzwischen hat auch schon der
lieferdienste seiner tür geklingelt das
ist einmal hier vom lieferdienst gleich
noch mal richtig schön in den entstehen
im vergleich ich sehe das habe ich schon
wieder vergessen lange nicht mehr
dargestellt die haben hier noch brokkoli
die haben noch lauchzwiebeln mit dabei
aber wie gesagt ich hab jetzt einfach
das an gemüse genommen was ich da hat
und das ist auch so ein rezept ihr könnt
alles mögliche an gemüse noch mit dazu
nehmen wenn jetzt so brokkoli dazu geben
möchte dann ein tipp von mir gebt den
wirklich in den letzten fünf minuten nur
dazu denn sonst ihr dazu weich und dann
schmeckt der meinung meiner meinung nach
nicht mehr so mein gericht ist jetzt
auch fertig und es ist ein bisschen
flüssig weshalb seiner diesen trick gibt
mit der speisestärke bzw sie könnten
auch mehr neben statt dessen aber so ist
es halt auch glutenfrei wobei expertin
sarah die sich glutenfrei ernährt ist
dann das ganze rezept eigentlich der
glutenfreie oder ist dabei wie wenige
wissen nicht wohin also wird zwischen
sind ja auch gut finden aber wenn es
keine kartoffelchips
dann ist es komplett glutenfrei jako
also alle die sich glutenfreien gerne
müsstet ihr wahrscheinlich den reis
weglassen ist auch mit den frauen ich
muss mich nicht mehr damit befassen wenn
man selbst nicht nur tim frey ist
befasst habe ich einfach zu wenig damit
so ist einfach nur verrückt ich habe
jetzt hier einfach nur warmes wasser
genommen so und rein damit und dann
einmal noch einmal aufkochen und merkte
dass es so ein bisschen einlegt und ich
habe noch einen zusätzlichen die top
tipp für euch ich mag ist ja ich hab's
doch auf instagram immer wieder gezeigt
ich mag es ja wenn man in so gerichte
einfach nochmal hefe flocken gibt es
gibt einfach noch mal so einen würzigen
geschmack viele vegane nimmt das auch
als käsigen geschmack ersatz und ich
gebe das gleich noch mit dazu könnte
aber auch weglassen ist komplett euch
überlassen
[Musik]
also ich habe zehn hamza dafür den test
erst aus wir haben rückenwind
verkostung hier vorbereitet sie ist ein
echt nix
okay ich hatte dich holen man würde es
vom optischen direkt sehen und wir
wollen dich nicht mögen also haben sie
dann muss sie forschen ich habe einmal
von die verhandlung gestellt das ist das
was ich immer so bestände venlo ließ
bislang woche bekommen genau dann
bestelle ich mir immer das so und jetzt
probierst du zwei varianten du weißt
nicht ob es halt das von den fahrern das
von livorno sich macht das überhaupt
nicht so groß er warte man redet nicht
zu großen noch weiß nicht was passiert
so du weißt jetzt in mainz ist oder das
vom lieferdienst mund auf
wir beschreiben wir eine gefühlslage wie
kommst du darauf dass das ist das
schmeckt so flach einfach wo denn zwar
gewürze drin aber diesen so lang waren
sich bei solch man hat ja sagen das
klingt zwar voll gemein und von mir aber
das schmeckt wirklich sehr deutsch
gewürzt also fehlen noch so liefen beide
reihe sie so schlecht denn am reis
schlechter ist klebrig und so weil sie
so lustig ist okay wir haben sehr dass
wir jetzt eine interessante erste
meinung jetzt kommt das zweite gericht
jetzt ganz ruhig hoch machen ich meine
ich mag sehr ähnlich auf eine kamera die
kraft ich muss sagen das war recht
eindeutig und ich muss sagen ich habe am
anfang zwar gesagt ja natürlich ist er
nicht verdient viel viel schneller aber
dadurch dass ich drehe verzögert sich
deshalb auch wenn ich nicht trinken
würde und das kochen würde ich glaube
ich wäre so realistisch in maximal 20
minuten fertig mit allem was uns
eigentlich ganz gute zeit die
stoßrichtung geschmack schärfe drin die
gewisse schärfe gehüllt sind sind geil
das mixed raus frisch am point der
anschlusspunkt deswegen verstehe ich
auch nicht was bestimmte
inhalte liegen müssen ja ich mag dich
macht sich aber ich mag es also aber
selbst gemacht schmeckt für mich
persönlich auch immer besser und das
krasse ist im endeffekt habe ich nur
salz pfeffer und das curry gewürzt dazu
getan und mehr ist das ganze ist gar
nicht dieses übertriebene exotische und
ihr müsst
also ich warum und was machen wir als
nächstes
schaltet man nochmal in die kommentare
was habt ihr das letzte mal beim
lieferdienst bestellt was bei dir in
eine pizzeria stimmte zu diesen pizza
mit alle italiener jetzt die ohren
zuhalten
ich setzte sogar noch einen drauf ich
habe meine pizza bestellt mit sauren
gurken und würstchen der song willst du
ja dafür aber schreibt mal ein video das
format findet auf solch gefällten ob wir
weitermachen sollen und ansonsten durch
mal sagen sehen wir uns beim nächsten
mal tschüss
[Musik]